hello and welcome to a live broadcast
from Yale University I'm Eric Gershon
human intelligence takes many forms one
of these is emotional intelligence the
ability of people to understand use and
manage their emotions Yale is a pioneer
in the study of this aspect of human
psychology and we're fortunate to have
with us today two of the fields foremost
scholars as well as an important new
partner in Yale's research program
Peter Salome is Chris our juris
professor of psychology and
president-elect of Yale University the
author of hundreds of research papers
and more than a dozen books he is a
central figure in the development of
emotional intelligence as a concept and
field of study his 1990 paper emotional
intelligence co-authored with John D
Mayer is a landmark in the literature
psychologist mark Brackett director of
the Yale Center for emotional
intelligence and a widely published
scholar is co-creator of the ruler
approach to social and emotional
learning this approach fosters the
development and social and emotional
skills in children of all ages as well
as in their mentors and families from
the Marcelino book theme foundation in
Spain we're pleased to have an ego
saiyans de mietek a genious he is
general director of the foundation which
works to mitigate poverty and promote
social development in Cantabria or
region on Spain's
north coast the foundation and yale will
undertake a collaborative research about
the roles of art and creativity in
developing emotional skills gentlemen
thank you for being with us today to
talk about emotional intelligence and
some of the details of your exciting
plans together Peter let me start with
you and ask you if you would to define
emotional intelligence what is it how do
we identify it and why is it important
to measure thank you so much appreciate
the opportunity to speak this morning
let's start with an assumption that we
make and that assumption is that we have
an emotional system because it provides
us with information so emotional
intelligence essentially is the ability
to access and use that information to
take advantage of our
oceans in thinking and in motivating
behavior now more particularly we think
of emotional intelligence as a set of
skills and it's a set of skills that
concern the use of this emotional
information and when we look at
emotional intelligence we cluster those
skills along four dimensions the first
set of skills concerns the ability to
identify emotions in oneself or in other
people so this might include
understanding what you're feeling my
ability to look in your face and see
your expression and get some sense of
how you might be feeling the cues might
be verbal there might be nonverbal
second dimension of emotional
intelligence concerns understanding
emotions so how they change over time
how they might blend together in
particular how to use language to
describe them third area of emotional
intelligence involves using our emotions
so how do i harness my emotions or the
information provided by emotions and use
it to guide the making of a decision the
solving of a problem or particularly
relevant for today's conversation the
production of something creative a
creative act
finally we're interested in the
regulation or management of emotion so
my ability to manage my own feelings
calm myself down cheer myself up
psych myself up but also my ability to
manage the emotions of another person so
I see that you are anxious today and I
do something that helps you calm down or
I am speaking to a audience over the
television and I am trying to figure out
a way to engage them to make them more
interested right that's an attempt to
manage their emotions so again emotional
intelligence for us is a set of skills
having to do with you
the information that is part of an
emotional experience and to do that by
accurately identifying emotions
understanding them and understanding the
language we use to describe them using
them in thinking and in a motivating
behavior and then regulating them in
oneself and in others mark if you would
elaborate a little bit on how you go
about measuring emotions and how you use
those measurements to generate some
effect sure so as Peter mentioned the
model that he and Jack Mayor develop is
called the ability model of emotional
intelligence which means that we think
of emotional intelligence as a real
intelligence and therefore try to
measure it as such
with that being specifically is that we
take a performance based approach more
specifically we want to know how people
reason with and about their emotions
versus what they think about their
emotional life and we've done a lot of
research to show that the performance
based assessment seems to work the best
what that means is that for example in
the first branch of emotional
intelligence in perceiving emotions and
others people are given actual facial
expressions to code and so it's how much
emotion is present or not present in a
face for the using emotions we asked
them questions to consider that you know
if you're in this state emotion state
and you're going to do this kind of
activity is that conducive to that or
not for understanding of emotion we're
testing people's actual emotion
vocabulary and for their ability to
regulate emotions will use situation
judgment tasks which are scenarios that
people have to think about and then
generate effectiveness or rankings and
effectiveness for different response
options maybe what's most important is
that over the last ten years or so since
these measures began to be developed
we've done a variety of research
projects in workplaces and schools with
individuals interacting with each other
in task groups with business school
students many other kinds of projects
where we measure these skills using a
tool called the Mesquite which is a test
of emotional intelligence again
operationalized as a set of abilities
and we try to show that one scores on
this test predict important outcomes in
each of those environments and in the
best studies I think show that emotional
intelligence scores predict outcomes
that are important over and above
standard intelligence or the kinds of
personality traits that are typically
measured in Psychological studies and at
this point I think we've been able to do
that in a way that's fairly convincing
that suggests that we are measuring
something new and different measuring it
with some reliability meaning with
stability over time and that it is valid
that is that it predicts an important
outcome in in ways that we couldn't
predict it before yeah so the you know
when you think about the theory of
emotional intelligence we're interested
in how are these skills helping people
live better lives and perhaps an ego you
could tell us a little bit about the
work that the Allen book team will be
doing together yeah thank you very much
Eric thank you very much mark and Peter
and I want to thank you to thank the
people that are following us from
Santander I know in this small city in
the north of Spain this project has to
do with the social aim of the most
important project of the history of the
bottom foundation is the Bodine Center
one also of the most important art and
cultural projects in Spain the Bolton
Center is going to be an Art Center to
be part of the International circuit of
world-class art centers is going to be
obviously
the the main meeting point in the very
center of some time were to fertilize
with art and culture the city life but
it also is going to be a place to awake
creativity through words it's going to
be a place that is going to use art to
generate to help to manage speed and
mark or saying emotions in a way that it
awakes it and blocks our capacity of
creating no the the capacity of creating
that we really need in Spain and in
Europe at the moment because we are in a
moment in which it is clear that we need
to find new ways of doing new things and
this is what I said that this is one of
the of the of the main elements of the
social vocation of the Art Center no we
are going to use visual arts mainly
because it's going to be an art center
theater literature dance cinema to await
the creativity as a set of children
youth and also adults in their daily
life in the personal life and also in
their professional in the professional
life no with Jo I think that we are
going to bring together along experience
that gel has obviously Peter Holloway
your new president ISM is the main
reference in the in the world is filled
also the experience in the foundation
because we have been also working in
social and emotional intelligence for
the last ten years
with a program which is called ocasion
responsibly that has things to do with
the rural program know and bring it
together this experience and with the
wonderful team that Marc leads in the
social and emotional intelligence center
in there in jail we really believe that
the bolting Center can become the
the leading institution in the world to
awake creativity through arts using the
arts this is what it's all about
I'll take in just a minute we're going
to take some questions from some
journalists in Spain following the
broadcast but mark if you would follow
up just briefly and talk a little bit
about how the arts what it is about the
arts it seems to be useful for awaken
creativity some I think a lot of people
think of arts as the product of
creativity yeah yes so we we come in
from very different directions you know
in the in type of research we do but you
can imagine that you know being in a
place like the voting center where there
are different types of art how that can
awaken the creativity in a person how
you can start looking at things from
different perspectives how you can ask
questions about the art that help people
to sort of reflect deeper in terms of
what emotions do you think are being
experienced in this piece of art what do
you think the artist him or herself was
feeling when he or she was creating this
piece of art so there are lots of
different ways that you can use art to
help great more creative people and it's
a the great thing about art is whether
it's music whether it's theatre whether
it's dance whether it's the visual arts
is it allows you to have an emotional
experience in a safe context you can
feel fear you can feel anger you could
feel great joy happiness feel sorrow you
can have that very human experience but
you can have it in a kind of contained
and safe way you can you can feel what
it what it means fundamentally to be
human and yet it can have a beginning
and a middle and an end and and then one
can move on and I really think part of
the role of the arts not the only role
but one of the roles that the arts play
in our lives is to give us the
opportunity to experience the broad
array of human feelings but to do that
in a manner that that is essentially a
safe one I think I think that we all
have the experience of how the art
transmitters emotions and helped us to
generate I mean what happens with music
with a different kind of music that you
can listen to when would you go to the
cinema to the theater No
so the the thing is that let's use this
use art let's use music to promoting you
the kind of emotions that are needed for
you to be creative know we were speaking
once I think that the blue paintings of
Picasso what did you feel when you faced
them
I always remember this film from from
Woody Allen saying after the Opera know
every time I listen to Vagner I want to
invade Poland this is that this is a bad
way not but but how do we feel when we
face art when art really manages to
connect us this is what we want to
explore is something that happens in a
natural way but we really think that we
can systemize we can decompose these
role of emotions in creativity and then
to find the way to use different kind of
arts to generate these emotions yeah
mm-hmm gentlemen ready to take some
questions from mark from the journalists
this one comes from a Lisa from LPS she
asks some cheap well firstly she posits
that some people believe school hinders
creativity and so she'd like you to sort
of address do you agree and do you
believe programs like this one can help
sort of reduce that tendency and promote
creativity within the school context
sure so you know the way education in
the United States at least has gone is
that we focus more on convergent
thinking than divergent thinking so I
believe very strongly that introducing
arts in the way we're doing here in this
project is critically important because
as you as you look at leaders in the
world they're not convergent thinkers
they're divergent thinkers and if we
continue to do what we've been doing by
focusing on the narrow one answer kind
of
solution we're not going to be building
the kind of leaders we want in the 21st
century yeah we followed in foundation
and quite interesting debate about the
verse to use for creativity in the
center at the beginning we use develop
let's develop the creativity then we
found ourselves more comfortable with
awakening creativity but then is
unblocking creativity and I think it's
not only the school who blogs UK our own
all of us now I can remember my channel
choosing some shoes and me my Wi-Fi nice
and I telling him some very Adi
don't you think we are blocking the
capacity of thinking in another way no
so let's let some block it is there and
I think there are studies mark you
should know much more or Peter I'm sure
about how creativity goes down as you go
up in the school and as you go as you
grow up one of the great things about
emotional intelligence on the other hand
is our data suggests that as you age as
you get older it actually goes up yeah
so here you here you have this paradox
right where it seems like as you get
older you're less and less encouraged to
be creative as you say and yet you have
more capacity to be creative because
you're more knowledgeable about your
emotions and about the information that
the emotions are conveying to you and so
how do we get this back on track it's an
opportunity
exactly it's an immense opportunity
gentlemen we'll take another from Javier
at el mundo Cantabria he he's interested
in having you elaborate a little bit on
whether emotion leads to creativity and
or or if it's sort of the other way
around that is that the creativity will
foster yes
nothing is one-directional in our work
you know so we think of things
influencing one another but the the
direction that we're taking for this
project is to look at how emotion States
for example helped to generate
creativity so indigo was saying a minute
ago about music and arts and you know
I'm remembering a project that we did in
a school system where we we put
children's at different mood states and
then we have them go to
different rooms and they had to create a
project and what you noticed was that
the the the students who were in the
room when they were playing very sad
type of music they drew something that
looked very sort of depressing and
low-energy and sad and the students who
were in that high energy room in the
yellow room we call it drew something
that was much more bright and expressive
so you know but you have to be put into
this experience and then you have these
kids come back together and they can see
wow like you were and you were feeling
that when you did that and you were
feeling that when you did that and that
I believe does open up people's eyes to
be more creative one of them one of the
things that in a way our culture leads
us to believe is that somehow our
emotions our feelings our kind of noise
our kind of background noise and it's
best to ignore them but in fact one of
the things that our moods our emotions
provide us is a change in mindset a
change in our perspective the world
looks differently to us in when we're in
one mood versus another and in a way
that's the key to creativity it's one of
the keys to creativity how do I think
about something look at something
consider something from multiple points
of view from a new perspective and so if
we can actually harness those natural
changes in our moods and emotions as
ways of looking at something through
different lenses
it might be that process might be the
key to becoming more creative I think if
you think about being creative I don't
I'm not next but noise is a personal
experience now the first thing is to
dare to be creative he after that then
you have the capacity that you can have
whatever he depends on your situation
but dating together and have to be
willing you have to be willing to first
will and to there because there is the
the possibility of the of succeeding or
not know so it dirty nor not depends
much more in your mood that it was you
know or the knowledge or whatever no I
think it's quite evident and now a lot
of it has to do with the types of
questions that we ask is to think about
right if we ask them to just solve a
problem that has one
sir how can you be creative about that
but by giving kids opportunities to look
at art and do activities that require
them to come up with multiple respond to
either the possibilities I can create
yeah speaking of kids we have a question
from Maru at AFA Cantabria and who asks
is this probably for an ego is the booty
foundation considering expanding the age
range of the folks involved in that sure
I mean now we are we are we are doing
this in modern I don't know in a natural
way makes in Arts with education but in
the in the center we want to bring into
the center like like a Mac a magic box
for creativity young people children we
even committed the foundation that our
Chairman media bought in did it last
year every school in Kentucky is going
to be able to use a center at least one
day of the year because we have many
schools but also for adults for business
people for doctors for politicians if
they want know whoever wants to come and
to experience art to become more
creative in their lives and I think this
is something that we really need some
someone from from a Spanish newspaper
was asking me this morning and I
couldn't explain why creativity is
important because I see it said it we
find new ways to do new things
no in not only children here mo at El
Diario Martinez asks and any we can
address this question really what do you
consider the most innovative aspects of
this particular program that you're
doing together
and this is go ahead go ahead I want to
say it like I can I think that you know
my colleagues are running of Chevak who
is really going to be the manager of
this project is an expert on creativity
and you know we're working on is really
and together with the foundation is this
model of how you know a theoretical
model for how emotions creativity and
art all work together and in doing
empirical investigations with adults and
children to test these these models so
to us
that's really the big piece of this is
really understanding the theories and
how emotions drive creativity how Arts
Drive creativity and how arts emotions
and creativity work together briefly how
would a I'm sorry go ahead not only was
moving in a more gentle way and I would
say that using art is innovative the
bottom center is going to be an art
center everything is going to go around
the arts art is going to be in the heart
of the center it's mainly an art center
but it's going to use arts and these
that looks just a slight difference is
very important art are a mean for the
development of the people we're going to
thank you for your TV but again is that
the objective of the art our Renzo Piano
the the project is is done by Renzo
Piano the architect and art makes people
better people this is the the claim of
the center no that would be
I remember when so saying once that the
boudin center should be a Tumtum sending
a message from Santander the jungle of
the Contemporary Art this is the message
art makes people better people xavier
again he's asking if gentlemen if are
there specific results that you have
from your research that that that
suggests the benefits of developing
emotions for society well the kinds of
studies that we've done so far have been
more of a psychological nature but what
we do know for example is that
developing these emotional skills in
adults for example makes them better
leaders in their workplace better able
to work together in a collaborative way
to cooperate to problem-solve in a in a
group context better able to interact
with a stranger somebody new somebody
they've just they're meeting for the for
the first time for kids in schools we
know it makes them like school better be
more attentive learn learn better
interact with teachers more effectively
so I think all of these interpersonal
outcomes that we just that I just
summarized reaching out to strangers
cooperating working in groups solving
social problems learning better in a
classroom you know it strikes me that
those are kind of the building blocks to
better to better society to positive
social change right to at least at the
individual level to a kind of world that
we would all like to live in and so in
that sense well we haven't done the
studies that show that our work on
emotional intelligence changes culture
those are those are big links hard to
make I think we have done the work to
show that developing these emotional
skills links to the behaviors that when
collected together in a society lead to
a change in culture although as you
think about it we've done some in our
most recent research well we can't look
at the culture of a town or a country
we've actually been able to shift the
culture of classrooms and schools
absolutely so we're going from the micro
to macro yeah that's one of the things
that's so excited exciting about this
project to yell into our laboratory
because it's really a chance to move in
a much more macro direction than we have
in the past to really get out of the
classroom and get out of the laboratory
and be in a world class yeah cultural
center and also to bring it again to
that to the classroom I mean we cannot
be just something strange you know of
course I think that all I think it's
happening something in the schools in
the educational system you know in the
whole world know now we know thanks to
Peter and others that there are
different kind of intelligences we
cannot stay just teaching what we were
teach when we went to the school we all
know that our fellows the ones who had
better records are not necessarily the
ones who had more success in their in
their professional life in their
personal life in their the kids whatever
no let's let's develop these new
intelligence that we know that we have
well in the past people were scolded for
being creative yeah right you were in
trouble for not sticking with the group
Maru at AFA asks again if if you think
that this will be part of a series of
collaborations between the foundation
and the university sorry said again it's
this part of a series of collaborations
well I think this is a big collaboration
itself there's a three-year
collaboration no we're going to begin
the theoretical part and then we're
going to prove we're going to go and
test what happens it doesn't end the
collaboration before opening the center
it will go on when the center is already
open this is very important mm-hmm right
so part of our work is to not only work
together to build these theoretical
models and understand the the work but
once the center is open we'll be using
the activities in the center and testing
the impact of those on ple okay and and
at this point you imagine and this is
from Pierre MO at El Diario whether
other institutions will join the
collaboration or and and of course a
little bit about who will be running the
center in in Spain just a quick note on
the emotional intelligence side yes you
know we now have a network of
collaborators all over the world very
heavily represented in Spain actually
and over time I could imagine those
collaborators joining with us on this
project we already have a team in place
but it's such a rich network of
psychologists primarily working on
emotional intelligence that we want to
take advantage of them and I think we
also have to bring into the project the
people knowing about the dark arts not
from the psychological point of view but
from no more shutting off in theatre in
dancing music we're going to organise a
summer course this the year in Santander
we're going to bring together experts in
social emotional intelligence with
experts in
to see how we can use them use them I'm
sorry to do that no the question about
the manager of the center is a question
that has been done lots of times in the
incent and there and I think this is the
the perfect moment to say you know that
taking into account that this is an art
centre and this is the main thing but
that we are going to use this on the
show the center has three aimed local
global because it's the Art Center local
because he's the new meeting point in
Santander and then social because he's
going to use art no so it's going to be
and this is like an announcement in
front and there is going to be Fatima
Sanchez she's the the actual who runs
the mark and Peter know her you know the
educational program in the foundation
for the last ten years
she's now at the Tate Modern she has
been spending six months they're
learning and also given them our
expertise in social and emotional
intelligence and she will be back and in
some weeks she will be starting to
manage the the center we're going to
look and we already started a
professional search International for an
artistic director someone has to help
the the Commission the Art Commission
led by Vicente totally the ex-director
of the Tate Modern for the art program
but Fatima is going to be the let's say
the executive manager of the of the
center excellent general we've got just
about a minute or so left any closing
thoughts that any of you'd like to make
go for it I'm just very very
appreciative really on behalf of Yale
University for this collaboration and
others that involve the foundation and
and banco santander because our
university is enriched by it and we of
course hope the world will be enriched
by it we are very optimistic about this
kind of work and just honored and
delighted to be a partner with you in it
for us president elected as you can
imagine is also an honor not to be able
to collaborate with one of the main
institution educational institutions in
the world to give scientific strengths
to what was just an intuition and it is
already a conviction okay yeah and I
feel the same I echo your comments and
just say that we're oh we've always been
a lab now Center that focus on the
application of science yeah it's going
to be a sight this is a great
opportunity for us yeah
gentlemen thanks very much for joining
us today and thanks to all of you for
your questions and for watching take
care join us again in the future
bye-bye thank you very much thank you